children as young as six months old are  now eligible for the coronavirus vaccine  that vaccine is made by pfizer it's  given in three doses president biden  marked the occasion with a visit to one  of the d.c area clinics vaccinating  young children he's calling it a huge  step forward in the fight against kova  19.  it's a very historic milestone  a monumental step forward the united  states is now the first country in the  world to offer safe and effective covet  19 vaccines for children as young as six  months old  doctors are urging parents to get their  young children vaccinated so they're  protected against the virus and starting  today the health district is offering  those covet 19 vaccines to kids as young  as six months you can find the full list  of those vaccine clinics at 8newsnow.com